you know it might be time for everyone
involved just to admit that this
franchise already managed its mischief
[Applause]
[Music]
hello folks so I'm gonna talk a little
bit more about Harry Potter and reminder
of my credentials Slytherin
actually officially sorted my Patronus
is a squirrel I don't know if I've ever
mentioned that one before so yeah I I'm
a I'm a fairly big Harry Potter fan read
all the books seen all the movies into
you know some of the you know just the
community of fans I just I really enjoy
Harry Potter a lot and the more been
thinking about like look it's no secret
that I think the fantastic beasts
franchise was an iffy idea and isn't
working you know you can check out my
review of fantastic beasts to to see me
just go on about how much of a mess that
was unfortunately I've been sitting and
thinking on it for a bit now I think it
there may honestly not be a way forward
with the Harry Potter franchise that
isn't going to yield diminishing returns
I think that all they can do is just
milk this thing till it's dead I don't
actually think that a change in
direction and an another option is gonna
save this thing and that's really sad
for me to admit now I had sort of two
things spur on this entire line of
thought the first was a video done by
Bob Chapman who is a creator who I
follow don't always agree with him but I
he does a good enough job of explaining
his thought process that even when I
disagree with him I get where he's
coming from so he did one on Harry
Potter in general as franchise and one
of the things he brought up and he kind
of meant
in passing he said one of the reasons
that it was odd that fantastic beast is
even a thing like in the form that it is
is wouldn't the most obvious
continuation of the franchise be a new
bunch of kids at Hogwarts and he's right
actually on two counts he's right from
standard sort of movie executive logic
it by movie executive logic if you've
got something that was successful as
many elements of that as you can keep
and do again do it again so that would
be the obvious thing but um even beyond
just standard Hollywood wisdom big
sarcasm quotes um
he's right on another factor as well
because one of the inherent problems
with the fantastic beasts entire thing
is that the initial hook of Harry Potter
was just the appeal of going to wizard
school I mean as invested as we
eventually got in the characters and the
conflict that was what got people
interested that's what got people
initially invested in the thing the lore
the world lore and all of that was a
great way to add flavor to the
excitement of wizard school awesome but
the lore was just that it was flavor so
to do a movie that's basically just
laying out lore which is what fantastic
beast has kind of turned out to be is
kind of ill-advised because yeah it's
set in the world but it's missing the
hook it's missing what actually got
people invested and that doesn't
necessarily result in a bad product I do
believe it has in the case of fantastic
beasts but that's not automatic but it
does kind of mean that you're just
you're just sort of narrowing your
audience as you go because that core
idea that initial pitch of Harry Potter
wizard school that got a lot of people
in what's the pitch on fantastic beasts
well there's a build-up to a war and it
was like people who aren't already
invested immediately they checked
like I can't imagine that there's really
anybody going to the fantastic beast
movies who was not already Harry Potter
fan that pitch doesn't win new people
the pitch of wizard school won a bunch
of people with the book won a bunch of
new people with the movie and I think
even now continually it keeps winning
new fans cuz that initial hook that's
brilliant in its simplicity and its
appeal and fantastic piece just doesn't
have that at all and the the thing is
though when I stopped and thought about
it I don't think that idea of doing like
the next generation of Hogwarts it would
be certainly truer to the original stuff
than like the original stuff in terms of
the hook and why it's appealing than
fantastic piece is I don't think that
would actually work very well either
because Harry's story is too big and I
mean that in a lot of ways I mean it
feels like in many ways Harry Potter's
story and how it connects to Voldemort
story combined basically makes his life
the most important life in the Wizarding
World for probably a couple of
generations like there'll be stuff that
goes on after this that happens after
this but nothing else is gonna seem as
big or as momentous so if you if you
take new characters and you set them at
Hogwarts aside from the potential of
just you know having it feel like a
knockoff of the first because there's
enough that you could do to have the
students not feel like the original trio
so there's a new flavor there you have a
couple of old characters you know
showing up but you can basically focus
on new characters like that could work
but one of two things is gonna happen
either it's not going to involve things
as big as Harry Potter's story
ultimately ended up being in which case
it feels smaller more pedestrian and
honestly probably better suited to TV
like that that's the Asterix I'll put on
this if I think the best in terms of the
quality of the finished product the best
thing that could be done is a next
generation at Hogwarts as a weekly TV
show I think that would result in the
best product because you could actually
have it be smaller things and focus
primarily on the classes into school
conflicts and not have to have it
ultimately end up being a world saving
thing on a TV scale but movies are
expected to have a large scale
especially if there are already movies
in the series and they've all if not
initially started that way eventually
became incredibly large-scale it's part
of the same instinct that unfortunately
drove The Hobbit to be turned into a
much you know more significant event in
the history of middle-earth than it ever
should have been oh and that was also
Warner Bros Warner Brothers really ok
need to not start down that path because
that could become a tangent but the
thing is like that wouldn't be
acceptable as a movie not acceptable to
executives who say well it's not as big
and honestly audiences might feel the
same as well given how big the movies
became in terms of the narrative and the
scope of everything so if you set a
movie in Hogwarts again but it's not as
big it feels kind of less significant
but if you try and make it as big and
you try and incorporate big
world-shaking VIII events in with the
school again well that kind of makes
Harry storey less special because now
it's like how often does this crap
happen in this world and it just makes
the whole thing not as triumphant and
that's actually I have talked about this
on video that's one of the issues that I
that I've had since the very concept of
more Star Wars movie set later on is
that I think the while I actually quite
enjoyed um force awakens last Jedi not
so much but and I ultimately liked it
enough that I set this issue aside it is
a problem for me that the very existence
of the force awakens inherently
undermines Return of the Jedi
because it means that that victory over
the Empire was ultimately temporary and
well I know it's realistic that like you
don't defeat one guy and then there's
galactic peace forever that's you know
that's the fantasy of it I should be
able to think that now I can't and I
think that would be one of the problems
with trying to go larger-scale
again and I think that might even be
part of the problem with crimes of
Grindelwald but you know again I don't
want to rehash that and the other thing
is we actually now had kind of a test
case for what it might look like if the
franchise tried to go back to Hogwarts
and that's the curse child and that's
the second thing that happened that made
me want to talk about this I finally
finished reading the curse child which I
have been trying to finish for over a
year I finally knuckle down and finished
reading the dang thing but first of all
overall thoughts on the curse child
there I have no doubt that it probably
works very well on stage cuz it's very
clear reading the script that it is a
spectacles show and spectacles shows so
like for comparison wicked the Phantom
of the Opera
those are big spectacle shows and a big
spectacle experience honestly you can
get away with a lot of cheesy stuff
wonky plot turns conveniences it's
pretty forgivable because the experience
of seeing it is so incredible and I do
suspect that it probably works decently
on stage reading it flat-out and and I
and I like I can make that adjustment
I'm used to reading scripts but it's
it's a weird thing like structurally
it's for acts ooh hoo stage is something
at four acts it's good and the entire
fourth act feels more like a hastily
thrown together sequel to the end of act
3 than it does a natural continuation of
what's going on and but this is not a
review of the curse child but my point
is fan reaction to that for from people
who've read it I don't I actually can't
I didn't bother looking up a ton of
reactions four people actually saw the
thing but the reactions from people who
read it was lukewarm at best because it
did kind of the best that you could do
with trying to continue this franchise
it has new student characters at
Hogwarts
it's got score Scorpius and Albus who
actually think are good characters with
a good dynamic that is distinctly
different from the Ron Hermione Harry
dynamic so you've got them but then
ultimately it all circles back and comes
around to Harry and Voldemort and you
get that for God's sake don't we ever
get to just win thing by the end in
addition to a lot of other stuff that
kind of goes along in the course of it
that kind of irked me again it's it's
decent there are you know there are some
parts of it that are good some of the
emotional moments some of the the
parental stuff particularly between
Harry and Albus actually work pretty
well connected with me decently but I
finished it I'm like that wasn't great
and then after I saw Shipman's video I
found myself thinking this might be
about the best balance of elements in
terms of what the true hook of this
franchise is and not just trying to feel
like they're taking a do-over to tell
the same story again and it still
doesn't quite work now obviously Warner
Brothers as much as I have very little
respect or expectation of them as a
studio they are in an awkward position
because they can't actually do what they
would want to do because of how much
control Rowling has have I been saying
Rowling throughout this or rally I'm
trying to fix that because I've now
learned to shake a rolling but how much
control she has is why they're doing
fantastic beasts instead of doing um you
know and more years at Hogwarts because
you know again studio logic Hollywood
wisdom is prequels are risky like that's
that's not a great angle
go so that that's not what they would
have wanted but if it's what she decided
to do with how much control she has over
the property they're kind of stuck and
that might be the other factor here
which is that rolling since finishing
Harry Potter that the series has
basically spent her time just expanding
lore and there's nothing wrong with that
Potter mores fun additional details are
you know the drip feed some of them are
fairly interesting but to go back to
trying to write an actual narrative in a
world that you've been doing nothing but
lore build in for the last few decades
are not few days now decade plus maybe I
can't remember one of them the last book
came out now but she's lost the threat
of what the narrative hook was and she's
just she's just relaying more and more
and more and more lore at this point and
she has too much control for them to say
we we need to go in a different
direction so I think she's lost the
thread of what the appeal of this stuff
is because you know people you know fans
fans absolutely do talk about the lore
but what is the first thing that a Harry
Potter fan will tell you it's what their
Hogwarts house is it's not which branch
of the Ministry of Magic they would work
at you know the the bigger the the world
outside of Hogwarts added a lot of
flavor to the story of Harry Potter but
it was never what people were there for
and she seems to have lost sight of that
and then Warner Brothers
you know I've ranted about them enough
in other videos I don't want to redo it
here
so between the originator the studio
that's driving the primary new narrative
thing now because she's not writing
books and given the nature of these
scripts they may not they probably
wouldn't be great books but they they
would have been better as books then his
movies between all that I'm not I don't
think
Harry I don't think new Harry Potter
material is gonna get good again which
frustrates me to no end because I really
love Harry Potter as much as a high more
oven than not when I make videos about
it I'm complaining for one reason or
another but the thing is like I complain
because I love it
and I I want it to keep doing well and
when something that you love keeps
stumbling like this it is just really
frustrating and now sort of looking at
it and feeling like I don't think it can
do anything but continue to stumble
that's not a fun realization for me to
have
I also hope I'm wrong I also hope that
down the line maybe I doubt the next
fantastic Beast movie but down the line
something new Harry Potter related comes
out that makes me go know I was wrong
they figured out a way to make this
fresh again and recapture the magic I
hope that happens I don't think it will
though the current state of Harry Potter
as a franchise overall and the future of
it can it get any better if so how
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments and
let's talk about it there's a whole
bunch of stuff to do down there as well
like subscribe obviously patreon link
hey I'd appreciate the support um plus a
whole bunch of other stuff other links
to other things that I do P o box
whatever it's all down in the
description give it a look-see
if you want if not that is okay because
at the end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]